Gore Vidal's latest collection is called
dreaming war blood for oil and the
Cheney Bush Kunta in it he argues that
large corporations American foreign
policy and the Bush administration are
the catalyst behind America's war on
terror recently he sat down with nation
magazine editor Katrina vanden Heuvel
and WNYC radio host Leonard la pate at
the New York Society for ethical culture
it's an hour and 10 minutes
okay can you these are times when what
used to be called liberal is now called
radical what used to be called radical
is now called insane what used to be
called reactionary is now called
moderate and what used to be called
insane is now called solid
neoconservative thinking
so it is very good to be here for the
head in the heart to be here tonight
with people of sanity and passion who
have come to here a defender of the
American Republic perhaps America's last
small are Republican gore Vidal
and thanks to our co-sponsors the New
York Society for ethical culture the
public concern foundation and Democrats
com
it is almost as if in normal times a
magazine like the nation is a holding
action waiting for a moral or political
crisis to happen and it has as gore
Vidal has said we are not so much on the
brink has fallen over it and I would
guess that all of us in this whole
tonight weep for what is happening to
our country we know that it wouldn't
when it comes to defending our fragile
democracy to restoring citizen control
of our government or reining in
corporate power were in the fight of our
lives and that fight needs a media needs
a gore Vidal who will defend the spirit
and letter of our constitution and defy
the bullies who say questioning this
administration and its motives is
unpatriotic at the nation we refuse to
be cowed or silenced even when called
names by Aussie rags masquerading as
newspapers
and by their electronic media affiliates
determined to make us what gore Vidal
would call the United States of amnesia
in this time of thuggish conformity the
nation's independent rebellious and sane
voice refuses to be drowned out by false
patriotism conglomerate ization and
Murdock you zation that spirit of
Independence runs through the Empire
we at the nation a nation Institute er
building yes Empire from the largest
circulation weekly of political opinion
in this country to a national weekly
radio show to an internship program that
has launched hundreds of young
journalists a kind of guerrilla network
into the mainstream and alternative
press and now nation books a new coke
publishing venture of the nation
Institute and thunders mouth press it
delights us that a great and ferocious
opponent of empire gore Vidal has
contributed to the success of the nation
empire his book dreaming war in its
eighth week on the New York Times
bestseller list in its umpteenth week on
the LA Times bestseller list that
success seems good evidence to me of the
hunger in this land for antidotes to the
right-wing bigots and blowhards who mark
it treason and slander and bias and
[ __ ]
no one is better suited to skewering
their idiocy Xin Gorby doll master
essayist historian of power and Empire
stretching from Rome Washington DC to
Hollywood defender of the Republic for
which it truly stands and a believer in
argument and provocation without end not
war without end let me end by returning
to another time in our country's history
a few years before 1865 1865 being the
year the nation was founded by a group
of abolitionists Wendell Phillips one of
the leading abolitionists was asked
Wendell why are you so on fire he
replied I'm on fire because I have
mountains of ice before me to melt
since Phillips left the scene those
mountains have grown ever higher and we
need more fire to melt them so tonight
let's melt some ice with gore Vidal and
let's take the fire out of this hall and
melt that Shanee bush hunter which
coração skillfully indict s' I turned
this evening over to Leonard low-paid
America's gift to the interview and host
of a Daily Show on WNYC the leonard
lopez show thank you
and go I understand that you'd like to
start off by reading some things yes
but very briefly and I look up from time
to time in order to give an air
spontaneity heart sink when they see a
great sheaf of papers and a grim look on
the speaker's face I'm delighted to be
here and particularly delighted as so
many old friends I see here and there
and one of the great heroes of my
lifetime politically is in this fall
Senator George McGovern
one of the only boats I have never
regretted making Jorge run this is the
year I'm also very grateful for him that
he got me the biggest laugh I have ever
had in a hall it was in 1972 hmm when
Nixon won and there was not much to
laugh about and I was speaking in Boston
a large youthful audience and the
questions afterwards and somebody said
how could you do how do you explain that
we here in Massachusetts are the only
state to vote for McGovern and I said
well I could complement you and say
Boston is the Athens of America and they
started to blow dutifully and I said no
no no I said it's not that I said since
the beginning of the Republic
Massachusetts has been the most corrupt
state in the Union and you know a crook
when you see one
I was not asked immediately back so that
to that venue there are a couple of
quotations I'd like to throw out to sort
of set a theme to why we are here
there's a quotation from Benjamin
Franklin and you cannot find it in any
of the high school history books and not
even in proper history books except
rarely and it occurred Franklin has
always been depicted as one of the great
bores of the founding fathers and he of
course was one of the most interesting
in 1789 he was at Philadelphia for the
making of the Constitution he's old
dying and he finally read the handiwork
of his fellow conventioneers and he
didn't like it but he thought about it
and then he got up he made a very
interesting speech he said I think that
this we should accept this Constitution
for all of its errors and omissions at
that time the Bill of Rights was not in
there I think we because it will give us
for a course of years good government
which is what we need right now and then
in due course as it would give good it
may be a blessing to the people if well
administered and I believe that this is
likely to be well administer and then
only and due to the corruption of the
people in despotism which will be the
only form of government suitable for
them this is as dark a statement as
anyone has ever made they got around it
the best of the high school history
books I saw American Pageant I think it
is said that they were so afraid for
Franklin he kept going to dinner parties
and
conversation was quite brilliant they
were terrified that he would give his
true opinion of how this thing would end
so they had a couple of young men going
around with him sitting on either side
so when Benjamin Franklin but let me
tell you about the Constitution and say
I could hear that's the salt
mr. Franklin I thought of that needless
to say when Franklin's prophecy came
true in December 2000 when the Supreme
Court bulldozed its way through the
Constitution in order to select as their
president the loser in the presidential
election of that year despotism is now
securely in the saddle is it due to the
corruption of the people or I thought
about what he is corruption the founding
fathers were always many of them on the
verge of it others in the Congress's
worse the blankets didn't get to Valley
Forge because it couldn't pass Congress
that was sitting in Philadelphia
corruption has always been with us but
when it becomes so total that you allow
an election not and to make no contest
there was no outcry across the country
when this terrible manipulation took
place and then of course Enron and
Anderson it has taken for granted that
these great companies are like this that
CEOs are taking all the money that is
not nailed down and people out of work
but with no relief to fall back upon so
now I think what we might chat about is
the despotism is really in the saddle
and the Old Republic is a shadow of
itself and we now stand in the glare of
a nuclear world empire with a government
that sees as its true enemy we the
people the prior to our electoral
franchise war is the usual aim of
despots and serial warfare is what we
are going to get unless we'll help
well wisher in new Old Europe and from
ourselves awake at last we can persuade
this peculiar administration that they
are acting on their own and against all
our history the other night on CNN I
brought the admirable Aaron Brown to the
full-stop
I do not do 19th century fox--
I brought into a full stock with not
with Franklin but with President John
Quincy Adams who said in the 1820s on
the subject of our fighting to liberate
Greece from Turkey the United States
goes not abroad in search of monsters to
destroy if the United States took up all
foreign affairs she might become the
dictators of the world but she would no
longer be the ruler of her own spirit or
soul should we be allowed in 2004 to
hold a presidential election here in the
homeland
I suspect we shall realize that the only
regime change that need concern are
again spirit or soul is in West
Washington President Adams is long since
dead and we have now been in the Empire
business since at least 1901 conquest of
the Philippines the local population did
not want us there we promised them
independence we killed 220,000 them
while subduing them a few years ago
there was a significant exchange between
the then general : power and the then
States person Madeleine Albright like so
many civilians she was eager to use our
troops against one of our men named men
named everywhere we look there's
somebody lurking who might one day find
a special death ray and turn it on us
one could hardly sleep at night knowing
these dangers all around
when Powell said no she said what's the
point of having all this military and
not using it he said they are not toy
soldiers but in the interests of
fighting communism we did spend
trillions of dollars until we're now
threatening to sink under the wet weight
of so much weaponry much of it we have
shifted over on to Afghanistan and Iraq
I suppose it was inevitable that sooner
or later a new generation would get the
bright idea read that thing in a Sunday
Times today on the neo-cons
and their background intellectually
which turns out to be from a book by my
friend Saul Bellow called ravenstein is
that it you know Leo Strauss was
actually a nice old-fashioned classicist
but he's been taken up by wolf of it and
Cheney and a lot as a kind of guru since
he seems to believe Empire is very
important that empire is based
classically on force so why stop fooling
around with diplomacy and treaties and
coalition's and just use our military
power to give orders to the rest of the
world a year or two ago a pair of
neoconservatives put forward this exact
notion mr. Kagan and the young mr.
Kristol I responded in print that if we
did so we would have perpetual war for
perpetual peace which is not good for
business then the Cheney bush hunter
seized power although primarily
interested in oil reserves they liked
the idea of playing soldiers too and if
you call call it a war you had wartime
powers for the president last summer
Congress received from the
administration a document called the
national security strategy of the United
States as the historian Joseph Stromberg
observed it must be read to be believed
the doctrine preaches the desirability
of the United States
it's becoming to use Adams word dictate
reserve the world it also said used to
be Nicaragua is quite enough you know
now it's going to be Korea China it also
assumes that the president and his
lieutenants are morally entitled to
govern the planet it declares that our
best defense is a good offense the
doctrine of preemption is next to clear
as a matter of common sense inquiry
right and self-defense America will act
against emerging threats before they are
fully formed now this would this is kind
of madness this is not what we started
the country for it's not what the rest
of the world wants I mean it is if I'm
sure at this very moment good general
Ashcroft brave officer of the hunter
that he is is probably up in Utah
arresting Mormon boys before they grow
up and then kidnap eight girls for
future wives they're going to do it we
know it we know the danger if you put
them all in prison in concentration
camps those girls are safe thank God
Danes are danger everywhere we look
article 1 section 8 of the Constitution
says that only Congress can declare war
but Congress surrendered that great
power to the president in 1950 and has
never taken it back as ex senator
Simpson he was one of my favorite clowns
said so cheerily on TV the other evening
the people of the United States don't
declare war the commander in chief does
so in great matters we are not guided by
law but by faith in the president whose
powerful Christian beliefs preach real
faith is the substance of things hoped
for the evidence of things not seen in
response to things not seen the USA
PATRIOT Act was rushed through Congress
45 days after 9/11 we're expected to
believe that it's carefully crafted 342
pages were written in that short time
actually it reads like a continuation of
Clinton's post Oklahoma City
anti-terrorist Act the Patriot Act makes
it possible for government agents to
break into anyone's home when they are
wave conduct a search and keep the
citizen indefinitely from finding out
that a warrant was issued or not they
can oblige librarians to tell them what
books anyone has withdrawn if the
librarian refuses he or she can be
criminally charged they can also collect
your credit reports and other sensitive
information without judicial approval or
the citizens contempt finally all this
unconstitutional activity need not have
the slightest connection with terrorism
early last month the Justice Department
leaked Patriot Act 2 known as the
domestic security enhancement act as of
January 9 2003 it has not yet gone to
Congress but it is certainly
leaked and I saw parts of it here's a
provision if an American citizen born
American citizen has been accused of
supporting an organization labeled as
terrorist by the government he can be
deprived of his citizenship even if he
had no idea the organization had any
link to terrorism provision of Act two
is also made for more searches and
wiretaps without warrant as well as
section 201 secret arrests in case the
citizen tries to fight back in order to
retain the citizenship years he was born
with those federal agents who conduct
illegal surveillance with the blessing
of high administration officials are
immune from legal action a native-born
American deprived of citizenship would
presumably be deported as today a
foreigner born person can be deported
also according to American citizens the
provision has some wonderful language it
says he can be deploy stripped of his
citizenship deported from the United
States then they suddenly thought well
what country would want him you know and
we better rephrase this because he can't
of course get a passport as he doesn't
have citizenship so the thoughtful
divisors of our domestic security
enhancement authorizes the Attorney
General to deport him quote to any
country or region regardless of whether
the country or region has a government
well it sounds like heaven to me
anyway that's that's how you get rid of
the Bill of Rights and one big sweep
back in 39 our greatest historian
Charles a beard wrote the destiny of
Europe and Asia has not been committed
under God to the keeping of the United
States and only conceit dreams of
grandeur plain imaginings lust for power
or a desire to escape from our domestic
perils and obligations could possibly
make us suppose that providence has
appointed us his chosen people for the
pacification of the earth those
americans who refuse to plunge blindly
into the maelstrom of European and Asian
equalities are not defeated or neurotic
they are giving evidence of sanity not
cowardice of a doubt sinking as
distinguished from infantilism they
intend to preserve and defend the
Republic America is not to be wrong or
Britain it is to be America
did that last quote from Charles beard
in mind I'm reminded that one of your
characters had I have no control over it
some can somebody turn it up please one
of the characters in the Golden Age your
last novel the end of the American
chronicles says that America started out
wanting to be like Greece and ended up
like Rome
what is your response to Neal Ferguson's
are a suggestion that the real problem
for Americans is that we refuse to
acknowledge our imperial role in the
world that we are hypocrites because we
we do it we're proud of it and at the
same time we make believe that we're not
impaired well you've got to remember
mother that was England I mean they
invented hypocrisy we're mothers
children at least we were in the
beginning of the country
we couldn't disappoint mother by
speaking out honestly that we wanted to
Christianize those Indians whose land we
took and we did they all had Christian
burials essentially we were Undertaker's
for Jesus
you sometimes quote Tolstoy as remark
that history would be an excellent thing
if it were only true Leo knew a thing or
two and that's that's why you have
written historical novels along with the
nonfiction Oh historical novels I'm
generally so disappointed in what I call
court history which is most of what we
get from a khadeem it's history written
for I don't know to get tenure a lot of
it or to play please the trustees paint
a golden picture of the management which
is corporate America nowadays I mean I'm
very friend a friend of mine has written
a very successful book I will not
mention his name is I don't want to hurt
his feelings somebody will tell him
anyway but about John Adams making him
into the cuddliest teddy bear you ever
did see I have no idea who you talk I
know you don't and you're not going to
draw me out
Adams was an incredibly brilliant
thoughtful and marvelously neurotic and
filled with vanity and self-pity they
seem to go hand in hand in certain
characters so he writes this book and we
don't get the Alien and Sedition Acts
which is the background of what is going
on in Washington now with the USA
PATRIOT acts in which we no longer have
due process of law yeah couldn't be
arbitrarily arrested deported in its
interim you don't mention that about
Adams and then you write a big
bestseller where you have a chance I
would say that is if not history that's
historical biography at Jeeps I've done
my best to correct certain views that I
thought I write them as novels
I don't invent any I don't have George
Washington looking out the window
wondering why did I marry Martha I don't
know if he ever thought that and I don't
care if he ever thought that
when I have historical figures in a book
whatever they say that I record they
actually said as far as the record goes
I've got it from letters diaries
journals and the main up characters are
simply my way of commenting far better
to have a couple of invented people or
near invented in my case would say John
hey secretary to Abraham Lincoln he kept
lots of journals I will occasionally go
into his mind to quote something that he
had written but not that he had said it
it gives you a sense of the atmosphere
of the time what they were like when
they were talking I'm doing one now on
the for Yale on the founding of the
Republic and I'm narrowing it down it's
a slender volume called inventing a
nation and I've got it down to the one
person who's never mentioned that we
don't know about and don't really care
about it's George Washington and without
him it wouldn't have happened and he is
terribly interesting if you give him any
the time of day is not as interesting as
Jefferson with a slave girl which I
wrote about back in in burr
I was 1973 Dumas Malone was a great
court historian an academic who done six
volumes biography of Jefferson I mean
each book would sink Manhattan
and he attacked me for this for my view
of Jefferson and said Vidal is
subversive this was in the era of
communism I suppose when he were says
that Jefferson could have had an affair
with Sally Hemings which DNA is now
proved if indeed he had well I thought
that is this the way to write history
that the evidence for it is so great
then he says in the clincher no
gentlemen in the old South in the
Confederacy he was from Virginia - would
ever have an affair with a slave maybe
not an affair an encounter and I said so
I've responded to Malone and I said so
you are willing upon a false syllogism
to construct a false figure of Thomas
Jefferson I'm happy to say he died
thinking that perhaps I was right too
many other people had got to him on the
subject well it is really getting hard
to tell what is fact and what is fiction
just reading the newspapers and you know
that's mostly fiction
it's the new novel the New York for
example in the lead-up to the war with
Iraq the whole idea that Iraq posed an
immediate threat to the security of the
United States and that was before no
weapons of mass destruction ever were
turned up I'm I wonder if you think they
ever will be found well I suspect
they're planting them there right now
why
and why has the press pretty much
dropped out do you think that the media
have been subjecting us to weapons of
mass distraction because really
because right now what we're getting is
beyond the triumphalism is all this this
other stuff but the whole point of this
war seems to have been forgotten or
people are saying well it really didn't
matter anyway I would say a people with
what was once quite a good Republic
never perfect but it tended to get
better more liberal as I explained to
mr. combs is that he's I don't go on the
violent cold yeah and I said we were on
radio together and I said something
about well of course you know people of
your political persuasion want this war
and it was during the bill 11 he said no
no no I'm the liberal remember and he
made he made a mistake as I hoped he
would never answer a question that's put
to you particularly if you're the
questioner so I let him go on a bit and
then I said what do you think the word
liberal means I listen to you people
talk I'm a conservative I'm a liberal
you're a Hollywood liberal you're at
this you're that I said you use these
words you don't know what they mean I
said without liberals would have no
Social Security that was a liberal Act
of 1935 from from Roosevelt and Congress
without the liberal Roosevelt we would
never had the GI Bill of 1945 which gave
a whole new class of citizens to America
everybody could be educated solidly so I
said what do you think the word means
well he said it means to be relaxed
about you know free about things and so
I said no no
I said Webster's dictionary which as far
as I know is not a red front dictionary
defines a liberal as someone who favors
political action toward the extension of
democracy mr. combs is editor Mia Allen
:
Allen combs I have never heard you and
the many many few times that I've seen
heard you ever say anything that would
have extended the democracy tolerance
perhaps but democracy not well maybe
that explains why if we interpret that
and in another way that so many liberals
like Christopher Hitchens Paul Berman
Todd Gitlin Nat Hentoff have supported
this war do they see it as an extension
of democracy well if it's not aware that
mr. Gatlin was ever a liberal he used to
be a member of he was a member of SDS at
one point
oh yes everybody's been a member of
something some time or other and then
they do a mayor Copa and get forgiveness
you know it's it's that's a great thing
that the Christian Right did was a
celebrity falls on bad times becomes a
devout born-again Christian and then as
given work goes around the country
proselytizing as a whole new career as
Christopher Hitchens appointed himself
my heir years ago and I found him a very
bright kid I first knew he was about
twenty England the New Statesman we both
work for it and he's had a sea change so
he is no longer my heir
the dolphin I used to call him or
Delfino which is the word for dolphin in
Italian I never translated that mad
gente that hand to off is a worthy
figure but I've never and I know I'm
slightly I've never found him very
interesting on anything you know I think
they see their opportunity the money is
on the right look if you were and if you
need money and and attention they've got
all these little papers out there a
weekly standard they have always the
Mellon which is nice cape melons think
tank that was a wisdom which is to
collect up all of the flotsam and jetsam
of the intellectual world and overpay
them and have them produce speeches
which 4w has trouble mouthing but he
does get older at least at least they're
making him suffer when he has to read
I've been asked to remind you that cards
have been handed out and if you want us
to ask your question
with obviously not gonna get to them all
but please write your question down and
they'll be collected in a few minutes
now you've talked about the Patriot Act
but your hero as far as I can tell it
one of your major heroes was Abraham
Lincoln and he suspended habeas corpus
during the Civil War don't presidents
always tend to cut back on our civil
rights in times of well that's in the
car Lincoln acted under the Constitution
the Constitution said in case of
invasion or Sedition the president may
indeed suspend habeas corpus it's it's
in the article it's under the presidency
wherever there's particle for know
that's article one anyway Lincoln ulcer
Lincoln did a lot of pretty bad things I
mean he could never make his case he was
not an abolitionist as we know so he
couldn't be on moral high ground by
saying that he was gonna keep the cells
from succeeding in order to free the
slaves he had no intention of that he
was a unionist and he saw the country
would be broken and broken in half if
the south win he has to think of a
reason legal reason and he he got into a
rather mystical mood because there was
no constitutional the states had come
together of their own free will over
their own free will they could part that
was the understanding from the beginning
so he said when finally challenged he
said well I have done this and I am
committed we are committed to a great
Civil War because these states want to
go I have an oath which is registered in
heaven to preserve protect and defend
the Constitution of the United States
and they shall not go well that's how he
took it's just as well since it was my
great-grandfather not I who had to fight
in it just as well it happened
you quote another of the founding
fathers James Madison in war 2 the
discretionary power of the executive is
extended and all the means of seducing
the minds are added to those of subduing
the force of the people sounds like
something called Rove would have written
it's something he read say when you
quoted that were you saying that the war
with Iraq was waged in order to seduce
our minds and subdue the public's power
yes the hunter is after oil first of all
they're all oil people Cheney the bushes
conned elites of Rice's Texaco Exxon
they're about eight of them in in high
places now we cannot use the word
conspiracy anymore because that's the
the media has worked over that one if
you say something is a conspiracy oh you
believe in flying saucers
mm-hmm out-of-body experiences are hard
so I have advised everybody anytime I'm
on television and we get into the
subject I say it is not a conspiracy
it's a coincidence that they all work
for oil companies and certainly like a
war because you can suspend the
Constitution the Bill of Rights I mean
just think of it it's black comedy but
the comedy of we give the Pentagon vast
money which Bush then declares a war
which you can't do against terrorism as
it's an abstract now and you can against
the country so he goes in under wartime
powers and you can almost see a
commander in the field with somebody
from Halliburton beside him or Bechtel
and say okay take out the railroad
station we've got a very good model for
one now and so you take that out they
take out the railroad station in Baghdad
and then immediately they've already
signed a contract with the government to
rebuild it
the idea that you might not knock it out
at all that you might leave it alone
does not occur to them that would be too
simple so a fortune is going to be made
by bush and friends and then I advert
yet again to Benjamin Franklin if this
is not the total corruption of a people
I don't know what is did you see the
letter that representative Henry Waxman
sent to Donald Rumsfeld earlier this
week pointing out that Halliburton
company subsidiaries have done work in
Iran Libya and Iraq
in fact Iraq as recently as 1999 in
spite of US sanctions against these
countries and he wondered whether the
Halliburton should be receiving new
lucrative government contracts I'm
wondering whether they shouldn't be
brought to trial or sent to a region
without a government
and hence no contracts but it is
interesting to see how they got away
with it well everybody gets away with
everything I mean the media is bought
the media is hopeless it has never been
more atrocious it has never been much
good in my lifetime certainly and I'm
reading a lot of 18th century press and
it was pretty lousy then but George
really went after Clinton how come
nobody's going after this man well they
will because he's going to fail the
economy is going to crash you you can't
just go on sand I'm just sick and tired
the way they're acting over there I'm
sick and tired of the fact that the
people didn't take the occasion of the
midterm election to change the Congress
till the polls remain very strong for
George W Bush I don't believe those
polls and anybody who's been in politics
knows that it's buried in selling
anything it's the way you ask the
question and a couple of times on
television they've allowed somebody to
get away with showing how it happens you
say in the after the vicious Grievous
attack of 9/11 by Moslems
zealous George Bush went to war for
America and for those dead in New York
and in the Pentagon and he is finally
won over Osama bin Laden and over
Afghanistan and over Iraq
Adam do you approve of that
sure I do
if you put it like that he's not popular
and once they figure out who he is now
who's gonna tell them I have you and I
can go around and talk to audiences but
you know New York Times will not cover
what we have to say will be buried
buried if present at all only certain
things can be mentioned other things
people are silent about I've never seen
people so silenced wherever you go they
seem to be afraid somebody's list
why do you think that is why do you
think that any kind of criticism is
being treated as treason today this is
is returning to something like what we
went through with McCarthy oh this is
much bigger than McCarthy he was just
one lone publicity mad senator who got
his in the end this is a very serious
coup to seize all the oil resources on
earth if possible certainly starting
with Iraq going into caspian sea oil
through the pipeline through Afghanistan
this is an all-out venture there then
when they saw how easy it was to pull
this off and no voices said no because
Congress the Democrats were too afraid
of being accused of yellow-belly treason
then they got bigger and bigger and what
the things they grabbed now they are
doing this to the Bill of Rights just
smiling
there goes due process of law bye-bye
this is atrocious stuff this has never
happened to us before we have never had
anything close to it yes FDR was a
dictator in World War two he did less
damage in the years of that war than
these people managed in a week or two
within the country with their Patriot
Act's and also to the alleged enemy here
X we still haven't found what it was
they did to us but we keep looking well
if you why do you predict that George
Bush will lose if first of all he is
pretty much taking control of this
country as you suggest and also the
Democrats really have nobody out there
there are nine candidates I don't know
who you favor right now I want George
McGovern to come back into the race
well by the way you phrased your
question you deliver the answer to it
you personalized it isn't doesn't depend
on one man or one woman who is magnetic
and so on and brilliant and right-minded
it depends upon a change in the
citizenry that they think that they can
do something about anything they don't
care at the moment and it's to make them
care well the economy is going to crash
you cannot sustain as much as what is it
five trillion dollars of debt that we
now have more and more money for
armaments less and less money for
veterans you can't go on like that two
million people have lost their jobs
since this President took oh well
yesterday 6% unemployment in the land
this is unheard of when we had a surplus
some of it done with mirrors and smoke
but it was a genuine surplus at the end
of Clinton that justice they got rid of
that and now they are going to in the
name of conquest or it will always be to
bring liberation to the era people
people that we've always cared so much
for we're going to roll up our sleeves
and gives them liberty and freedom and
the country just like ours poor bastards
and in your most recent book you linked
the events of 9/11 with Pearl Harbor in
ways that others have not can you
explain that Roosevelt wanted those the
genuine lover of not so much of England
yes he certainly hated and feared Hitler
and as of 1940 and I was very active
politically although I was a schoolboy
at Exeter I was the head of the America
first step there because we were having
a great debate about war and peace I
mean every school was arguing about it
and then we have Iraq a huge war and
nobody argued about it I didn't hear two
sides ever had made any coherency
Roosevelt thought that 80% of the
American people did not want to go to
war to stop Hitler or to go to war in
Europe for any reason at all save
England to restore France we'd had it in
1917 the first world war the only thing
that brought us was prohibition not a
good thing in liberal land and Roosevelt
then did something very daring it has
all been perfectly I quote Charles a
beer he wrote the first book on the
subject
Roosevelt maneuvered the Japanese who
had a treaty with the Axis powers with
Germany and Italy to come to the aid of
each other in the case of war he got
them to attack us at Pearl Harbor he
knew perfectly well something was going
to happen as far as we know he didn't
know that they had Pearl Harbor in mind
from what I got from mrs. Roosevelt she
said well we expect to be struck but we
thought it would be Manila next door
which somehow was better than Pearl
Harbor when they had they got the fleet
Roosevelt had been reelected president
in 1940 I promise you mothers and
fathers that no sons of yours will ever
serve overseas unless we are attacked
well he was honest about his his
resolutions to the people he kept the
faith there but he cut off their fuel
oil their oil supplies and scrap metal
Japanese had nothing left to do but
bombers hoping they could knock us out
for a year or so while they went down to
Java and grabbed all the oil wells which
they pretty much did but they hadn't
realized a lot of people realize in
Japan realized this was a fatal blow but
they shouldn't have done it anyway then
we had a great ally at that time for
Roosevelt getting us in the war she was
Hitler clever old Adolf took Clare's war
on us which gives you know there's the
game now we have now we're in the
European war it was a funny moment at
the Nuremberg trials from justice
Jackson was a prosecutor asked
Ribbentrop the foreign minister
he said just out of curiosity this is
during a formal questioning but he's
said you know oh as an aside he said
would you tell me why Hitler declared
war on the United States after Pearl
Harbor and Ribbentrop said well we had a
treaty with Japan then he said Jackson
why was that the only treaty you ever
honored in 20 years but are you
suggesting by linking the two that 9/11
was similar in that way of whether it's
true that that FDR knew or not and many
historians disagree with you on that
let's say it is tripping fewer you know
anyway then did george w bush or some or
his administration know that osama bin
laden planned to do something on
anything like they're asking the wrong
person
i am not intimate with those people so i
don't know what they knew one of the
reasons i never went in for journalism
was that i don't like to give my
opinions as facts i'd like to give the
facts preferably facts that other people
haven't found out yet or don't know
about but that year now we're in the
realm of
ability and with this gang I would say
anything is possible that I there's no
proof I leave the charges to others for
the proof stuff although you have there
was an essay from August 2001 you say
James Baker Department of Justice's
Council for intelligence policy has
already warned us terrorism is
everywhere on the March that was a month
before 9/11 you wrote that essay yes we
were getting lots of warnings we also
know that Mubarak of Egypt Putin of
Russia three members of Mossad had
warned our government that something
unpleasant was going to come out of the
sky
and he did nothing and you quote a New
York Times report that is early as 1996
Pakistani terrorist Abdul Hakim Arad
confessed to federal agents that he was
learning to fly an aircraft in order to
crash a plane into CIA headquarters that
is quite true that was in the New York
Times people say where do you get your
information I said well I actually read
these newspapers and anybody who can
read as much of the Wall Street Journal
as I have because they are very good on
facts stories particularly if money is
involved and I learned a lot from
watching Izzy stone was our greatest
journalist
and is he read everything that came out
of the Government Printing Office sooner
or later they blab everything and they
know nobody will ever read it I mean
it's just urgent stuff that T's keeps
coming out is he lost his eyesight as
glasses got thicker and thicker but he
would read this stuff and then he would
see a pattern and he would collate it
and then he'd we thought it was a great
prophet because he could predict what
was coming just promoted read well I
have followed the same path and my eyes
are also going and you say that before
9/11 there was a bush administration
plan to attack the Taliban was that an
extension no there was a Clinton plan
the Clinton plan that the Bush
administration picked up a record put
aside for a while well what happened was
that Clinton decided to go after Osama
bin Laden presumably in Afghanistan
contingency plans were drawn to strike
that Osama bin Laden and how how
elaborate it was I don't know I think it
was pretty elaborate because I think it
was going to involve invasion then
Clinton is voted out of office as a new
President Clinton decides that it is not
a really a fair thing to do to present a
brand new president with a war which he
is launched so sandy Berger who is his
national security adviser handed his
successor Condoleezza Rice this plan
said we have this in the works and it's
pretty much ready to go if you want it
Time magazine a very arcane recondite
place
published a big story on this summer
Condoleezza Rice said burger never gave
it to her and burger said I did and
so-and-so was also in the room well they
disagree
anyway what then happened after 9/11 was
pretty much we're all told the Clinton
plan that's how they could get it going
so quickly they thought it through we
have questions from the audience and
maybe I should well first of all before
we do that defenders of the president
would suggest that whatever you think
about the war within Afghanistan the war
with Iraq that the people of those
countries have to be in a better
situation today than they were before we
went to war well they have no buildings
I'll say that
and a lot of them you know were in bad
taste I mean it's urban renewal and
Frank Gehry in there forced urban
renewal now you just have to do that
every now and I'm sick and tired of
people and I got Halliburton there we're
gonna have ranch houses up and down the
Tigris and Euphrates and they'll have
ranch houses - oh it's gonna be a
beautiful place you see we only bring
good people this this person these are
questions from the audience this person
asks do you think Fox News has a finite
shelf life will Fox go the way of Morton
Downey Oh God you remember one down of
course I do
tears are already welling in my eyes
well let's say Fox deserves to go the
way it was Morton Downey yes
and they are so afar and they all shout
I've never heard such loud voices they
force their voices very high this I went
on a couple times with Chris Matthews
yeah oh it shrieks at you and the I
actually met him after I was in LA and
he was in New York or someplace we did
it
long distance TV and I saw him in some
book thing they've all written books and
he was signing his books and he came up
to me and he said I bet you don't
remember me and I said no I was on
television with you a few days ago no no
he said
you came to Holy Cross to make a speech
in the 1960s I said I remember that yes
he said well I was the guy who met you
and brought you to the auditorium and so
on well I have pretty good memory but I
don't really remember that oh he said if
you think I'm an [ __ ] now you should
have heard me then
he said I asked you that all the sexual
permissiveness now was giving rise to
things like anyway an immoral movie was
so so I mean like Mother Goose now it
was so you know inane I am healthy
healthy healthy like healthy the
morality had given birth to the movie
healthy and I started to laugh as he was
telling me the story so that's what you
did last time
well actually you were you were ahead of
the curve with a number of novels when
the first openly gay novels in America
than there was Myra Breckinridge before
anybody ever thought of transsexuality
there you were they thought of it to me
you said before anybody thought of joy
well people had thought of it but I mean
and we knew about Christine Jorgensen
already yes but it was not every
sixteen-year-old could talk about it as
they can today if Patriot Act this
person asks the Patriot Act to calls for
deportation of those who can sort with
terrorists even unknowingly and if the
bin Laden family invested 10 million
dollars in back tells Financial Group
where should we deport back tell that
this as reported in The New Yorker well
northeastern Guam is a very attractive
piece of real estate there's nothing
there but you know you could you could
bring in plants and so on
and you can even make it look like San
Francisco which is where their
headquarters is put it a cable car
somebody but we are in an odd situation
where Bechtel Halliburton our closest
allies in the Middle East other than
Israel Saudi Arabia have all supported
terrorists and yet we seem to look the
other way oh that's our job we don't
care about any of these things this is
all noise to distract the people to
convince them that Saddam had something
to do with 9/11 he didn't that he had
weapons of mass destruction he didn't we
knew it
Europeans knew it there's still some
real journalism going on over there
they're not all that better than
ourselves but they're not quite so
dishonest and they don't quite follow
certainly the USA government slide you
don't read anything in the New York
Times now again they've got a couple of
good writers they're like Krugman
who occasionally dare to tell the truth
which is sometimes involves unveiling
the lies of the administration but
they're not enough and television itself
is just hopeless
I talked to the set
I answer questions they didn't ask me I
just talked to them and I turn them off
interviewers on the more conservative
shows have often criticized you for
living outside the country spending so
much time in Dili I know you're moving
back to the US now but can you imagine
what they would have said if you lived
in France rather than Italy the first
thing I would have said would without
the French we would still be a
dependency of England
our George did not win that revolution
the French fleet did at Yorktown and for
us to go around you know in a sense
denouncing our betters their
civilization is older and rather better
than ours it is true we invented
cellophane and to rattle around small
pieces of bad cheese you know so I mean
we have our triumphs
this person writes you say it is the
fault of the people that we have a
despot in power what are your thoughts
on the anti-war demonstrations here and
across the world can that approach be
effective well we have nothing else we
can do except the demonstrations but
then the powers that be I watched I was
in LA I watched on television how
brilliantly the police saw to it that
nobody could observe on the TV screen
the size of the demonstration here in LA
I spoke to 100,000 people in Hollywood
Boulevard and they had a stage at one
end at La Brea and there were 100,000
people all the way up to Vine Street and
I spoke to 100,000 helicopters overhead
so if the audience got too interested
they'd come down very very low and make
a lot of noise but they finally went
away and not a word and the only time is
is much much better than the New York
Times this is not saying much but it's
better and it does occasionally feel
obliged to tell what happened how many
people were in a crowd but this time
they did because this was the big one
so they said you know some people said
it's 30,000 people and people seemed
unclear about it and so on
luckily a photographer had done a shot
behind the stage I happen to be speaking
that moment of the people all the way a
straight line of them up to Vine Street
and you could see it was a hundred
thousand people to come out perfectly
they say nobody was there and then they
have this photograph meaning that there
are subversives even at the LA Times
when we had the first anti-war
demonstration here the New York Times
reported a lower figure than the New
York City police did well nobody's
perfect this person asks could you
comment on W in his flight suit parading
around when he was AWOL from his
national of what when he was AWOL from
his his National Guard duty well he was
he certainly stayed out of that war and
Cheney Cheney when asked why he had
pulled every string to stay out of
Vietnam actually answered I had other
priorities well so did 13 million of us
who served in that war so I thought that
was a daring they don't care what they
say the country is theirs you see today
a little bio on Cheney and what's
wonderful kicked out of jail twice I
mean the question is how did he get in
drunken driving I mean it's just the
catalog of vices and abuses that keeps
on and all we get is you know Clinton
was a bad man because of that in turn it
looks like George Washington now I mean
she's got a job on television this
person asks if in the unlikely event you
were asked to advise a Democratic
presidential candidate what advice would
you give why an unlikely event
I've already been asked for advice and I
won't say what I said I would say that
the the main line to pursue is to
explain the loss of the Bill of Rights
now our public is so badly educated they
don't know what it is and it's not
taught in the schools properly
everybody's very vague about it never
use the word progressive and never say
we must go forward into the future
nobody wants to do that because it's
going to be death sooner or later so
don't do it to win you must always go
backwards we must go back to the roots
of our republic yes that's right we
probably should and I said a good word
is restoration let us restore the Bill
of Rights
mrs. Roosevelt was sort of my political
teacher upstate New York was she was
optimistic about people V people and she
said you know if you just take the time
to explain anything well understand it
if it is interesting to the minute they
just do their interest to understand
it's not difficult that's when she was
begging me to tell Jack Kennedy not to
talk so fast she said they can't
understand him I told him to slow down
and he said Eleanor Roosevelt told me I
was talking too fast no love lost
between those two if you could formulate
a new foreign policy for the US what
would the first thing be that you would
do mind our own business the country
from Washington through JQ Adams and
late later conservatives attended to
isolationism but they've been depicted
as a bunch of you know stick headed
Neanderthals who didn't want where
xenophobes didn't have anything to do
with anybody they weren't that we were
always a trading nation from the 18th
century on we supported ourselves by
trade but Washington made it very clear
that we must not have special friends or
special enemies we must have goodwill
toward all do business with all and that
was the most you could expect for what
then would you have done in response to
9/11 well I first would have
investigated what happened they don't do
these things for no reason
I would have gone to the UN I would say
we want a police action we've been hit
by something like the Mafia you don't
call out the army to go after the Mafia
in Appalachia in Italy they called out
the police to go after the Mafia and
they've got a great many of the leaders
and Sicily and they never bombed Palermo
once didn't you have ambitions for
office at one time in fact almost make
it well I doubled the Democratic vote in
1960 upstate New York for the Congress
then this it was really mine in 64 and I
decided I didn't want to go to the house
in fact I'd gone back to novel writing
and I thought it was better to write
Julian and to be one of 600 I have a
horror of anonymity and as Jack Kennedy
always said the House of Representative
is a can of worms
well I asked that because the last
question here is when are you announcing
your candidacy for the presidency in
2004 see you in Concord no Empire
we've run out of time I want to thank
you all for coming out here
come over here
let me get the book come along
where do we go here
we're giving them work out okay
dreaming war blood for oil and the
Cheney Bush Kunta is published by
thunders mouth press an imprint of
Avalon publishing visit a Boleyn pub
comm for more information